Melbourne has been the most livable city in the world for the past seven years.
But this year it lost the top spot to Vienna.
Home to Strauss and Schubert and famous for its coffee houses,...
...Vienna scored an almost perfect 99.1%.
But what makes a city livable?
The Economist Intelligence Unit has been analyzing this.
It has ranked 140 cities according to stability, education,...
...healthcare, infrastructure, and culture and environment.
Most livable cities tend to be midsized in wealthy countries...
...and with low population densities.
Copenhagen is the only other European city in the top 10.
Australia and Canada each have three cities and Japan two.
Western Europe and North America are the most livable regions in the world.
The Middle East and Africa the least.
While Asia and Australasia...
...are home to some of the world's most livable and unlivable cities.